dann wollen wir mal schauen wie das
cocktail video von kajomi angekommen ist
mist
wieso seid ihr nur noch zu zweit was
mirella vor müssen mir elo ist denn
mirella die schieben mirella ab aber das
ist die relativ egal wo bleibt denn die
dritte im bunde cashflows und mir
relativ zu das format in den arsch
niveau ist mirella was ist eigentlich
mirella anstatt einfach zu zweit ein
anderes format zu starten es nicht
dasselbe
wo ist sturm ii oder mirella ich hasse
es wenn youtuber versuchen etwas zu
verheimlichen was dermaßen
offensichtlich ist herr stellt mir
robert post mirella ist das privatsache
aber wir hätten schon gerne mirella
wieder dabei oder wenigstens eine
begründung warum sie nicht mehr dabei
ist was mit mirella ich fand es nicht
lustig und habe auch nicht gelacht was
mir aber ist schon so dezent auffällig
wenn man den dritten weg lässt ohne zu
sagen warum was ist eigentlich mit
mirella freefight etwas verpasst habe
aber warum es mirella nicht mehr dabei
wo ist mir elo ist mir egal wie wär's
mal mit einem statement schließlich habe
die reihe zu dritt gestartet und fast
jeder form ist mir elabo ist
wieso ist mir leider nicht mehr dabei
das ist eigentlich mit mirella die macht
schon länger keine videos mehr mit euch
wir erobert fehlt irgendwie warum machst
du nicht mehr mit mir herum ohne mirella
post mirella freni renner ist umgezogen
leute beruhigt euch ich vermisse in
videos mir selber wo es mirella
älter bist du fett geworden was ist
eigentlich mit mirella los sie wird
misst man keine ahnung was bei euch ab
geht mit mirella aber seit mitte 20
leute
[Musik]
hallo gabriela du sag mal wo bist du
gerade in köln man aber wie sollen wir
denn dann ein video zusammen drehen
du kannst mit der bahn oder mit dem
flugzeug kommen aber ich habe doch gar
kein geld für ein titel ja dann muss
halt irgendwie ein geld ran kommen
klicks mäßig läuft hat weil wir hier
menschen die rede habe ich grade
bekommen habt ihr euch nicht auch schon
mal die frage gestellt wo ist mirella
dann holt euch jetzt das neue wo ist mir
relativ er ist noch dran
jeder wird es lieben deine oma deine
mutter den vater ja sogar ein papagei
jeder liebt das bo ist mir relativ
schadlos
kommt jetzt euren kleiderschrank auf und
holt euch das neue bio ist mir relativ
und jetzt das t-shirt aus den neun wo
ist michaela kollektion
ihr werdet es lieben oh mein gott es ist
so schön und helft mir dabei noch kein
zu kommen vielleicht finden wir
gemeinsam ihre lang
[Musik]
ich muss so viele frisuren zu machen
also meine ganze zeit geführt das hab
ich halt wo ist mir egal wo ich meine
ich sehe immer anders aus wo bleibt denn
die dritte im bunde warum machst du
nicht mehr mit mirella dass da irgendwie
was ist eigentlich mit mirella muss mir
oder freddy ist ja gewusst mal gucken
uns die meinen das kind wusste mir
lauter freddy